في عقاب عمليه سلوان الكابنه سيعقد
اجتماعه طارق اليوم بمقر الشبك بدل وزاره
الدفاع ايضا همم تم اعتماد نشر وحدات
اليمام وهي وحدات كوماندوز كما تعلمون
تسمى وحدات النخبه كل هذه المعطيات مؤشره
على ماذا في تقديره
اللخبطه في صفوف الامنيه الاسرائيليه وفي
الصفوف السياسيه الاسرائيليه بدون نشاه
يعني لا احد لم يتوقع مثل هذه الوجود
الفعل
بالاكثر ما يعني
الجهاز الامني والجهاز السياسي الاسرائيلي
بدون ان شكله وان العمليات فرديه يعني كان
ممكن
يريح هذه الاجهزه الامني والسياسي لو كانت
العمليات هي من فصائل معينه من داخل غزه
او من داخل الضفه كان ممكن ان يكون رد
واضحه مباشر وكان يمكن ان يكون هنالك
اليات في ردود الفعل الان هي موجوده في
حاله اداره ازمه امام الشارع الاسرائيلي
يعني الشارع الرئيسي اكثر يمنيه
هو بحاجه لسمار سريعه لكي يراها يعني هذا
بالمناسبه يعني كان في طبيعه
الاعلان همم منفذ العمليه وابن ثلاثه اشهر
عمله كما تداع العائله لا شان له اوباما
كان مجرد تلك المنطقه فواضح جدا انها في
حاله همم باك واضح امام الراي العام
الداخل بالمناسبه والخارجيه لكن لديه
تعهدات بالنسبه للاداره الامريكيه
بودود الفعل والصيطه وعدم التصعيد يعني
ذكرت اذا كان رد الفعل لو كانت الفصائل او
وحده الفصائل الفلسطينيه بنات هذه العمليه
بما انه جاءت هذه العمليه بشكل منفرد
وعمليه الامس ايضا بشكل منفرد وفي مناطق
تتبع سيطره القوات الاسرائيليه بشكل كامل
فيها تعزيزات امنيه في حاله التاهب متالي
كيف يتوقع ان يكون الرد
هذه الحكومه موجوده الان في بحر الاختبار
وفي مرحله
13 استولى على وزاره الجيش الاسرائيلي
ليبرمان كان
يمنيه متطرفه لا تقل عن تصريحات بين كبيره
اليوم لكنه عندما هذا ما قبل الوزاره
ولكنه عندما استولى على الوزاره ااا يعني
حتى صاروخ واحد لم يخرج من اسرائيل في
اتجاه غزه فبالتالي يعني وفق هذه الماضي
اظن هذه كلاسيكيات بالمناسبه الكلاسيكيات
اليمين المتطوره دائما عندما ياخذ همم شده
الحكم في الوزارات يكون موجود
كثيره لكن الان نحن نتحدث بين لديه الكثير
من الشعبويه في ردود فعليه همم
واذا كنا نريد ان نقول ان هنالك نوع من
المغايه ونعمل هنالك انه مغير يعني يوم
امس ولم يكن لم يحضر ولا بعد ساعه ساعه
ونصف الى مكان عائل تنفيذ العمليه وكان
حضوره رجولا ليس كما بين كبير الذي يعني
عاهدناه سابقان في ناحيه الجيش الشارع وما
الى ذلك والقيادي وكان في حاله ظهور
الاخويا الامنيه التي وعد بها بدون ان
شكتفكات فبالتالي يعني وفق هذه المعضله
ردود الفعل هي ممكن ان
الان موجود
على اما ان تكون الشعبويه وبالذات في ظل
الاعلان عن المليشيات التي اعلنها اعلن
عنها بين كبير همم في داخل الجهاز الشرطه
فبالتالي هذا رد الفعل هذا ممكن ان اخذ
الى نوع من التصعيد الذي يذكر
2021 وهذا السنه جدا على كثير السنه
المحللين السياسيين العسكريين
الاسرائيليين همم هذا من جهه اخرى كذلك
ممكن ان نقول ان نتنياهو بالتالي ممكن ان
يكبر جناح همم بين كبير من جهه اخرى ويعني
يرضخ للاداره الامريكيه ورد هذا الازمه
بدبلوماسيته همم
كخبير همم في هذه الامور ربما اكثر حكومه
اسرائيل خبره همم في همم يعني همم ولديه
يعني
فبالتالي يعني المعده لو ممكن ان نتنياهو
يحاول تجيش تاجيل التصعيد ربما الى المقطع
اكثر ودود ياتي بوجود الفعل الكلاسيكيه
الاعتقالات الهدم والاستيطان شكرا لك من
حيث ايهاب جبارين الباحث المختص في الشؤون
على الاسرائيليه